hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today's video is going to be a review of
year four
season one i wanted to do these before
but i had completely forgotten to do
them in the past so pretty much we're
going to be going over
everything that happened in the season
give my thoughts on it and then you in
the comments can do the same
even though the season isn't done yet we
are pretty much at the point where there
isn't anything releasing besides maybe a
couple challenges and maybe an extra
loofest
nothing crazy like a new character or a
new map coming at this point that would
definitely be for next season
so as always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patchworks and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely
subscribe to the channel and with that
let's get started with today's video
so to go over what we got the first part
was the introduction of the new battle
pass system
of course battle passes aren't new but
in regards to for honor this is as this
was the first time we had something like
this
in the game i think this is a nice
system the current one we have
could definitely use some tweaking by
raising certain numbers like steel count
salvage count and all those and i've
done a video on what i think should be
added to the game next season in terms
of the battle pass so
if you want to see specifically about my
thoughts on that said battle pass click
the video in the top right
other than that though i do like the
weapons being in there i know some
people dislike it because of it
originally being free content but
personally i'm okay with the change i
don't like it i'd much rather have them
free but what else are you gonna add to
the battle pass to really make it worth
it
the execution signatures though were
really cool i don't really use them too
much anymore but the times that i did
use them
i did enjoy them a lot we also got new
armor this time around which is a huge
plus of course the armor was somewhat
well received but met with some backlash
from the community because the dlc one
characters didn't get any new armor
again
the last time they received armor was
back in season eight but it was more
just variations of current
armor they had didn't have any new
original designs
the other thing people mentioned is that
a lot of the armor wasn't exactly
out there so to speak so lots were just
close copies of other armors the
characters had already had
and not much changed minus a few
characters like jorman gunder for
instance
regardless though i was okay with the
armors a bit of a small change as well
but
of course still nice was that the
minions were also being changed we
haven't had a permanent change to the
minions before and it was really cool to
see them change
i am a big fan of the new models and i
feel like they were of course very
needed for the game
executions were also released with the
new season as always these executions
were great there hasn't been one season
i think where they've sucked maybe one
or two seasons they may have been
somewhat lackluster
or maybe not insanely crazy like other
seasons but even those still had a nice
amount of good executions
these have always been consistently good
so no ill wills here with this one
they're always fantastic there was also
two events this season the honor games
and the prince of persia crossover
blades of persia the honor games was
more of a celebration of the game
and added a lot of new things on the
samurai duel map and i missed this
because it actually made the game kind
of feel alive
not just an area where people were
killing each other but some sport was
involved everyone was cheering laughing
and just overall being excited to
celebrate
you know the game and all the
camaraderie going on this added new
emotes in the forms of musical ones that
sadly i don't see too much of honestly
i saw a lot of them during the event but
after it was over they kind of just went
away and i haven't really seen too many
i'm not sure if this is because people
just didn't buy them or had the steel or
maybe people got bored of it i'm not
really sure
but i think my personal favorite was the
community getting involved in having
artists artwork within the game that
changed per week
the game mode was really nice although
it kind of left a sour taste in people's
mouths
as they changed carousel of fire to
carousel of ragnarok
regardless i always thought of carousel
of death game mode and its variations to
be very mindless fun
so this didn't really stress me out too
much overall it was a really nice event
and still my top three sitting at number
two
just below apollyon's legacy the blades
of persia event was like i stated a
crossover event between prince of persia
and
for honor this added lots of changes to
harbor making a sandy desert outpost as
opposed to a dock like normal harbor
the cosmetic items of this event were
really cool as well and are still things
i used today on one of my characters
there's also the introduction of a new
event battle pass of course since they
added the battle pass per season
it kind of made sense that this is the
road they were going to take ultimately
it does fit for the game as it's way
better than before
now you don't need to grind and hope you
get the correct cosmetic item after the
game you've played it's now listed in
the event battle pass and it's free so
there was no negatives to this besides
maybe finishing too quickly but
other than that i think it was way less
frustrating and honestly way better for
the game in the long run
the game mode though pissed me off and a
lot of other people off as well it was
fun for a time after you know after a
couple days laughing at the prince and
his crazy feats but after a bit it just
kind of got annoying the prince's ai
seemed
extremely bugged sometimes it just
didn't make any sense why he was
attacking certain people
even in the second week when we were
able to get his item it just still felt
the same
overall nice concept but got really
annoying really quickly
at least for me we did get a mini event
thrown in there which was the april
fools event where the characters went
into mini sizes
and that was just really funny the
tracking felt off for some moves and
executions
and was once again just more mindless
fun and it was a nice change of pace to
the normal day of for honor so
i have nothing wrong with this to say
the last two things that happened was
the game being delayed till june and in
response was adding of the old year
three events back into the game which
were pretty cool
but i honestly think they should have
kept the game modes that were assigned
to those events not ones that have
nothing to do with the event
of course my original idea was just to
add other game
game modes and events from you know
years ago like apollyon's legacy but
with the current ones we have i'm
totally cool with getting the year three
events back
i just kind of wish the game modes had
come with it and then the last thing was
the testing ground changes to damage
there was a lot of interesting things
and a lot of concerns due to the 100
milliseconds of every move
not being shown as to remove delayed
attacks which could be troubling for
some players
as well as some weird damage numbers to
the moves mostly nerfing them across the
board
i enjoyed the nerfing damage as it went
well with their intentions of decreasing
damage so there was more survivability
while also changing stamina to go down
as
much during things like parries and
bashes overall i was cool with this and
hopefully it will be added at one point
in the game's lifetime i know a lot of
people weren't exactly too
highly keen on adding this to the game
but but overall i think this would be a
good change for the game
but for my overall general thoughts i'd
have to say that this is a really good
start to the year hopefully it just
keeps on getting better
come the next season and i'm really
happy with the outcome of this current
season but with that like to be if you
do enjoy guys subscribe if you're new
i covered the informational side of
honor the being the balance changes the
hero updates the patches and the leaks
even if we get to today with everything
happening within the world of 4 honor
and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribed to the
channel
and then take care guys see you in the
next video peace out
[Music]
you